Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192.
David P here is an individual who called in
very, very confused about my family background.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: I did.
So I can't help but notice that you're Jewish
and from Argentina.
Speaker 1: That's true.
So far, beautiful.
Speaker 2: Do you have a family history that
has ties to Germany?
No.
Like did you?
Are you from Argentina because your family
escaped the Holocaust and fled to Argentina,
along with a lot of other people who did that?
Speaker 1: Well, yes, to some degree, not
from Germany on my but basically three of
my four grandparents had families that went
to Argentina well before World War two.
One grandparent went to Argentina from Poland
very, very close to World War Two.
But nothing Germany related from Germany.
Speaker 2: No.
So did is that part of your motivation for
doing this show is to fight back against fascism
and Nazi ideology that the Trump administration
is bringing back to the mainstream?
Speaker 1: Well, I mean, listen, yes, part
of the reason for doing this show is to fight
against right wing authoritarianism, fascism,
etc..
But because I think those things are bad,
not because my family is from Germany.
So certainly some elements in that voicemail
that are mildly tethered to reality.
But the big picture not not quite so much.
But I still appreciate the opportunity to
clarify, folks.
The member town hall is tomorrow night, 6
p.m. Eastern, Wednesday, August 31st.
Member Town Hall.
Okay.
Speaker 2: The bonus show where you want to
make money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yes.
When you become a member at join Pacman dot
com, you get access to the bonus show and
you also get invited to participate in the
members only town halls.
It will be streaming live for everybody on
YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
Tomorrow at 6 p.m. Eastern.
But the participants will be limited to our
website members.
You can become a member in mere moments by
signing up at join Pacman dot com.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Bullied by a number of different legislative
accomplishments and a rising approval rating.
Joe Biden is going to give a primetime speech
to the nation about the soul of the United
States on Thursday evening in Philadelphia.
I will be covering it live in primetime.
We will talk about that speech and the timing
on the bonus show.
We will also talk about the launch of NASA's
giant moon rocket, which has sadly been delayed
after an engine issue.
I was looking forward to this.
We will talk about it on the bonus show.
And Pennsylvania Democratic Senate candidate
John Fetterman is calling on Joe Biden to
move towards decriminalizing marijuana ahead
of Biden's visit to Pennsylvania on Thursday,
which I agree with.
We will talk about all of those things and
more when I am joined by producer Pat.
On today's bonus show get instant access by
signing up at join pacman icon.
Otherwise we'll be back tomorrow with a brand
new show.